like about me on the computer in his
underwear
wasting his time in some chit chat room
going back and forth with some other
jerk off giggling like a little
school girl it was one of the first
times we see a somewhat realistic
depiction of therapy on television and
we see how people get frustrated with it
at one point he says therapy's a jerk
off you know it I know it it's therapist
like I actually don't know it and that's
some version of something I hear from
patients all the time they don't usually
use those vocabulary words but they will
tell me they get frustrated when is this
going to end what is the point of all
this what am I supposed to do with all
these feelings